we have uh we have a special guest
that's stopping in via zoom
to uh we're gonna talk to them real
quick do we have orlando
can we get orlando in here oh this is
great so he's got a new show
on tbs right now that's called friday at
midnight
and he's got an hbo special called
adorable the new show
is called rec league please welcome he's
already in it
orlando thank you for being here orlando
what's up moses how are you buddy oh man
i'm doing
great um how are you have you developed
any new coping mechanisms
for the second second lockdown nah brah
i'm just being me i just stay
stay what i do which is nothing and i'm
real good at it
so uh yeah and then just stuff fall some
um
on my table and then i just do it and
then
people cut me a check and i'm like all
right i can survive for a couple of more
months
who's giving you a check because has
anyone gotten their stimulus check here
where are you getting these checks from
yeah
daniel got his check daniel what did you
do get that check
can't tell you can't tell uh no orlando
say hello to daniel
super spreader the other kind of way i'm
super tired
i'm glad you don't tell people your
business that's how the way you got to
be
i don't tell people who i voted for or
where i get my money from
you know exactly because the irs is
always listening
that leads me to my first question
orlando don't ask don't tell
yes orlando how much money do you make a
year
what was that um so if anyone's not
familiar you have a new show on tbs
yes we have a new show on tbs uh thanks
to the wonderful people at rec
league me and my one of my best buds
forest shaw
we got to be commentators on the rec
league show which is a show within the
show which is on the super punch show
that airs on fridays at midnight on tbs
and me and my my buddy forest shaw and
myself we get to
commentate over people competing
uh over amazing fantastic
dangerous video games you know like uh
bus
simulator 18 we got these two
we got these two amazing people we have
uh
this was last week's you can also watch
it on on demand we had golden glue which
is
this kid he's a league of legends if you
know about gaming
they're like one of the top teams and
this other guy named alpha rad that has
like 2.5 million followers uh
subscribers to his youtube channel for
his video game playing
and we brought them in they didn't know
what they were gonna play
the good people like team coco set them
down they were like okay what are we
gonna play who are we gonna shoot
and we were like hey you're gonna drive
a bus and they were like what
and they were driving a bus so what
happens in the most popular game of 2020
bus simulator is it exactly what you
think you just like
getting to the stop on time here's the
thing my good buddy moses
uh i'm not a gamer my buddy for
shaw is and that's why he's my uh
co-commentator on this we were the
announcers
as soon as i saw the game and they
started playing it when we finished
uh filming i downloaded the game and i
started playing it it's so good you do
nothing you pick up people you give them
change
and you take them to wherever they're
going on the bus you're just a bus
driver
for a few hours or in my case i was a
bus driver for three days
so you actually started playing this
yeah yeah yeah i got into it it was so
relaxing and it was right during
election time so everybody's like where
are the votes gonna come in and i was
just like
i was just busting good people around
this
fantastic fake town it's kind of
european
but they're not playing with euros it
was kind of weird and you got to give
them change back it was good
i messed up a lot of the change if you
had any notes for the game would you
give
the bus simulator any notes of like hey
make it more realistic
make it like what's that pile of water
on the bus uh who's that person
screaming there
should be you know in my lifetime i rode
a few
buses and there was nobody trying to
uh have sex on the bus and there was
nobody doing drugs on the bus
and there was nobody uh exposing
themselves on the bus and i think that's
where bus simulator 18
dropped the realistic that's when i felt
like i wasn't really
like in that world like oh i miss you
know the people yeah
the real feeling of the buzz orlando you
need to get this started
you need to get the real bus simulator
yeah well i'm i'm already pitching to
them i'm talking about bus simulator
after dark you know what i'm saying we
just go in
and it's after dark you know you don't
the fare's a little bit higher but
you're gonna
see some stuff you can talk about on a
podcast later on
this this will be the hottest game and
is it coming out on on
playstation or xbox uh
it comes on on all platforms because i
just like to license it yeah i learned
that on shark tank
and you got a license to just just you
never
you never try to like keep it and have
build your own no just license it to
disney and
and netflix and everybody can guide you
i do think about that i watch shark tank
and i've only seen the episodes recorded
last year when all these businesses are
very confident
and they're like you know sharks in 2020
we're gonna gross 90 million dollars and
you're just watching like yeah
no you won't where did
[Laughter]
have you thought of any ideas in the
quarantine and in the lockdown that
would maybe work on the 2021
version of shark tank 2021 version of
shark tank it would be like
uh like uh air air
you know i i would think just
all hand sanitizers you know what i'm
saying
yeah but like edible hand sanitizer you
know i'm not a scientist
but it should be like you should be able
like what and like squirt
two little squirts of hand sanitizer on
your food and it's like yeah
because it's like we're still eating out
and people are touching our foods and
like i used to work in a restaurant we
don't
there's a lot of secrets in restaurants
yeah
uh have you have you done any of the
outdoor dining i guess has anyone here
done the outdoor dining thing it's a
little hectic
to eat in a restaurant right now
yes i have the one of my favorite
restaurants i'm not going to tell you
what it is because i don't want people
to blow it up and like you know like
you can say the name it's denny's
denny's is the favorite
underground comic underground comic
hangout
yeah you know exactly denny's is really
the bus
of restaurants yes
i've the last time i was at a denny's
was at 3am and this is a real
conversation orlando
uh the table behind us is like a younger
couple and the guy was just like
i cannot have another baby right now i
just bought knott's berry farm season
passes
that's a common that's a common
conversation at denny's
my good friend patton oswalt said if
you're eating at denny your night is
just starting or it's just ending
that that's just it that's that's it's
ending
if you've had a night out or it's just
starting if you're a hitman
hey moses i got a question for you buddy
did you already film your special
no i'm waiting to shoot a special when
it's when it's all safe i mean i
i don't want to do something like this i
want to kind of do it right
you you're lucky enough to have your
special
you're lucky enough to have your special
adorable already out
right yes and we're going to be in the
same family right your your
your special is going to be on hbo max
yeah
congratulations oh thank you and and you
too i mean you talk about your family a
lot
in your special was there any any
blowback from your
parents or family members that were like
actually it happened this way
uh yeah they all have their versions but
it's like everybody's version is their
version and i just kept to mine and i
got a check for it so
that too bad they don't have you know
yeah
that's it people hitting you for money
now mr big
no no i could no i could no no i cut
that off quick i'm not
you know that's the good thing about
just being me i'm like real good at
saying no like yeah the word
no to me like there's all these books oh
just say yes and go through life saying
yes
dude the word no is so powerful i've
said no to gigs
i've said no to birthday parties i said
no to friends
asking me to go move hey orlando i got i
got beer and pizza can you help me move
no no yeah higher movers
higher movers bro i said no yo i said no
like real talk i said no to my brother
for my niece's first birthday party
she was like hey are you coming to my
knees and she's your knees and
it's her first birthday and i was like
no no
nobody it's not for me i'm not there
i'll send her a gift i'll bring her i'll
see her on sunday
i don't you're not gonna let me in the
bounce house if you're not gonna let me
in the bounce house
and i can't bring my dog because it
bites kids
then why am i there the dog
is my baby the dog is my baby so why
can't i bring my baby
so what my dog bites kids my dog tried
to kidnap the governor of michigan this
dog is sinister
allegedly allegedly allegedly allegedly
allegedly are you excited about not
having to do a thanksgiving this year
then we have the best success
no no because uh listen man i have no
vices
but food and it's like this one really
hurts because i'm i'm
i'm about that food life 100
and if you're a fat boy and you know
about that fat boy lifestyle
you know that i don't really care about
carbs you know that lifestyle i don't
care how many carbs i can eat bread all
day long
you know and that's just me if you're
not because i'm a happy person if you're
not eating bread you're not happy it's
scientifically proven
i know that right but i'm going to live
10 minutes longer than you
oh yeah right that's gonna be cool
exactly exactly i'm good i'm good with
not living those extra 10 minutes you
know because that's right then
right then is when your hip gives out in
those last 10 minutes
and now you just you're just dead and
you pooped on yourself
meanwhile imma die just grabbing my
heart i can't breathe and i pass out
and fantastic there's a great story
hopefully i do it on stage
everybody can get free drinks after you
know because you have a great story
like how you saw me die yo i saw orlando
dying you go to the comedy store you
were there yeah i was there bro
let me buy you a drink tell me your
story
he killed himself himself
have you what's the last time you've
been on stage last time i was on stage i
did one of those drive-through with the
good folks over at the
at the improv i did the irvine improv
yeah and yeah and i was just
in uh arizona uh comedy at the comedy
house
oh arizona was fun i was there too and
arizona's fun because uh covet
never happened never happened there dude
it never happened it is never over there
and they were they were like i've never
rode the back of a wall
at a club i'm very animated and this
whole time i was just
like you guys nobody wanted to wear a
mask okay
i get it i get it to stay away from that
what what do you think the first
activity you're gonna do
let's say everything goes back to normal
tomorrow what would be the first
post coveted thing that you would do
post cover thing that i would do
it would probably be um just start
eating at all the restaurants at all my
favorite restaurants and
go get some ramen go get you know go to
tatsu's
go to the 101 cafe uh go to mamitas i'm
a food guy man i don't know about
that food life 100 or just stay home and
watch rec leagues friday
at midnight on tbs look at that so we've
got the answer it's plug your new show
would be the first thing you would do
yeah or just sit by
or download my new album that's coming
out on the 20th
adorable on itunes and the streaming on
all streaming platforms
which is what you're gonna do moses
you're gonna record your
special and then you're gonna launch an
album booyah
then you're gonna end up on the tonight
show and on conan
and it's gonna be fantastic brother
you've never been on conan
yeah jackie yeah i mean
yeah it's important move to put the
novel out right after the special the
novel is just about putting the special
together what it took to put that
schedule together
so eat get back out there hopefully not
eat in a tent
which does that make sense to you that
you're allowed to eat in a restaurant as
long as the restaurant
is outside inside
yeah i don't do that like i've been to i
was just talking about it
with my with my with my wife
and um we were talking about it and
yeah some of our some of our favorite
restaurants
have built this whole elaborate tent and
i was just like
well i don't like that because it's just
the spit it's just staying within those
tents
and it's traveling from ten my little
paranoia you know
that's why i need to go to our shark
tank and sell this you know
mouse sanitizer which i haven't
came up with this is it this is like a
shooting it's like a gun form it's like
a super it's like it's like
yeah it is orange super soaker because
you can't have guns in the street
especially if you have color on your
skin
i'm 100 in on this i i think it comes in
like a go-gurt package the hand
sanitizer
um um you know what gogurt package
actually worked it could be flavored
you know what i'm saying but it has to
be a limit kids can't really have that
much
because you could die but yeah yogurt's
fine because gogurt is like eating
directly from the tent material
i think we got something i'm down to
partner up with this idea
i'm willing to take i think it could be
just tequila it could be high grade
tequila like flammable tequila like if
you light it it'll catch on fire
and like you do that and you put that in
a goger packet and right before it but
then you can't drive see there's always
a catch
but this is our pitch so we'll leave
them on this but hands up if you guys
would invest
in our business this is the tequila that
we have
we're going all in and this is legally
binding by the way
we will find you we have a full party
where's dan olsen where is he he's
already
measuring himself with this idea well
orlando thank you so much
again tell people where they can they
can watch the show it's friday nights on
tbs
yes but before that i want to i want to
thank
thank a few people which is my my
partner at crime which is for
shaw uh ruthie uh wyatt
aaron blair they were the producers of
it i'm sure you know these wonderful
people the good folks at team coco
they're always uh looking out for me uh
jp buck
which is my brother man i love that dude
uh
my boy yeah uh you moses man i'm so
proud of you dude i can't wait to you
feeling your special you have that
energy that vibe and the whole world
gets to experience it
with that being said my album out
adorable
on itunes adorable orlando labor
adorable and this friday at midnight
watch on tbs
rec league which is within the show
super punch
within the show super punch it's a show
called rec league
where we talk this week we're going to
have miss may and stone mountain 64
and they will be competing in one
fabulous game called
goat simulator oh wow take a breath that
was incredible thank you so much
orlando you're a very kind person thank
you